[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
il ya plus mignonne de se défendre sur
terre nous sommes une plupart de ses
mines milliards et depuis la révolution
industrielle
nos actions ont fait augmenter la
température terrestre de 2 devenue hélas
on pourrait continuer pour vous
expliquer que le réchauffement
climatique c'est dramatique on a été
assez mauvais en dix matches comme ça la
transition écologique elle est
nécessaire et vous savez la question
qu'on se pose et qui nous embête c'est
comment nous on pourrait faire pouvoir
empêcher c'est choquant climatique
alors on s'est renseigné les en échange
autour de nous et puis avec l'ennemi on
a trouvé une solution commune
c'était celle de se mettre aux zéro
déchet zéro déchet c'est dans
intéressante
souvent il vous est expliqué par une
famille qui a pendant un an
les nouvelles
tous leurs déchets pour un an concluante
dans ce bocal et donc est souvent une
famille kilomètre zéro déchet et vivant
en ville où elles sont actives sur
charles trenet pour vous prouver que oui
c'est combatif de se mettre à zéro
déchet et de vivre environ
au final zéro déchet c'est quoi le zéro
déchet c'est trouver des alternatives
pour diminuer au maximum ces déchets est
comme ça on est en plus en trois ans
cohérence avec la transition écologique
en fait c'est comme si toute votre vie
on vous avait demandé pensez dans un
cadre au brésil que toutes vos habitudes
et des contenus comme bach ce cercle
pongiste en pleine nature
et quand conscience dérobés chez vous
allez vous mettre à changer vos
habitudes
à voir les choses autrement et à penser
en dehors de ce cerveau
là vous pourriez vous demander pourquoi
s'attaquer à un si petit phénomène
eh bien j'aimerais vous rappeler que
chaque année en france un habitant
produit en moyenne 530 kg d'ordures
ménagères est ce qu'on ne prend pas
assez souvent en compte et qui est un
peu caché ce soit les péchés issus des
processus de fabrication
ces déchets représente 14 millions de
tonnes par habitant et par an c'est
énorme c'est la partie cachée de
l'iceberg
et si on creuse rodez chez vous pensez
que ça donne quoi alors en se mettant au
zéro déchet
comment maladie d'une famille peut
espérer produire ça
de pêcher ce qui représente à peu près
ce local et en réduisant la part est
déjà subi portée de nos habitudes donc
exact et dans une ménagère cela résume
également fortement les déchets issus du
processus de fabrication
donc le zéro déjà un réel impact
écologique
maintenant ça vous apporte quoi à vous
personnellement alors moi par exemple
j'ai remarqué que mais vous aurez niche
et ça fait du bien au moral
je suis actrice et attention écologique
je fais partie des quelque chose qui est
plus grand que moi en fait ce final le
même du temps parce que marvel essentiel
je gagne de l'argent parce que j'utilise
des cousines qui dure et au final je
gagne en qualité de vie et ça c'est bon
pour ma part je me sens vraiment
actrices de la transition écologique
parce que je choisisse vraiment un gros
un actif je vais donner mon argent et
c'est en crayon à l'offre que j'ai envie
que la demande va pouvoir s'adapter
après et on a déjà vu ses avoirs du frac
et du bio dans les supermarchés
donc vraiment poussé cet homme
et avoir de plus en plus de commerces et
traille en pack
donc ce que j'essaye de vous dire c'est
qu'on en met une harare pouvoir entend
consommateurs on a aussi remarqué que le
feu repêché à développer notre
créativité ça va complètement routier
parce que travailler avec un minimum
tokyo autour de nous ça nous oblige à
devenir créatifs et inventifs et par
exemple le moi cette année mais comment
l'école a organisé un gala c'est moi qui
vous eu mon propre sac à main avec ma
propre vie et l'oeuvre pouvez vous dire
que parce que zéro déchet c'est
contraignant en fait oui vrai du tout
c'est comme apprendre à faire du vélo
au début en tout temps qu'on est plein
d'éclat tueur mais avec un peu un peu
d'entraînement ça devient normal ce fait
vous aurez douche et ça a été exactement
la même chose
en fait ce qu'on les batte et aux
heureux deuxième roussat des mois était
plus dur c'est de changer nos habitudes
on est vraiment arrêter de revient sur
le lancement est vraiment
on se met un contre un on a commencé par
des petits changements et on recommence
position aussi on a monté un club qui
tapait latinos on allume des ateliers
pour pouvoir partager toutes les
alternatives qu'on avait trouvé et
s'enrichit visiter des autres et vous
verrez quoi pour vous mettre au régime
et alors nous on a débuté par refuser
certains produits comme si on valide en
plastique par exemple
elle est remplacée par des départs des
objets en verre et en fait on avait
beaucoup plus attention à se poser la
question est ce que j'en ai vraiment
besoin et si oui on en a vraiment besoin
alors on va essayer de faire à partir
des objets qu'on a déjà celle de ses six
fabriqués à partir de ça et sur
mouvement alors on va essayer d'acheter
des objets d'occasion mais si c'était
toujours pas possible alors vraiment en
dernier lieu
là on va passer à acheter un mobile home
et de cette façon notre vie est devenue
plus minimaliste et ordre parce qu'on ne
cherche plus la concession possible camp
républicain l'objet non on rit des rues
saturées habileté que barça semblait
parce que s'il est réparable et ne
jamais leur rendement sont qu'angie et
ça ça fait raison
une tendance intéressante que sont les
loups tech pour faire simple et court et
le tnp ce sont des outils qui sont
fabriqués à partir de ressources
renouvelables ainsi d'accès et peu
coûteuse et ça ça va à l'encontre de
l'obsolescence programmée de tous les
appareils technologiques d'aujourd'hui
et de me la part de nos produits et vous
donner un exemple
j'essaie aussi de me prendre pareille de
choisir des produits qui soit adaptable
et pas comme on montre la publicité très
spécifique pour une seule action exemple
j'utilise ville est donc pour le ménage
la cuisine aussi est urgent pour les
cheveux quand vous avez faits ce rocher
mythique c'est absolument génial j'ai
trente univers
mais comment jeter concrètement et voit
ses réserves
bonjour moi j'ai commencé par la cuisine
j'ai remplacé comme vous le disais les
produits en phase iib les emballages
plastiques par les bocaux en verre et
j'utilise aussi des sacs en tissu pour
acheter des aliments en vrac
de mon côté de la salle de bain avant
j'achetais l'internet génique mouchoirs
en papier et autres
total espère remplacer par leurs
équivalents mais en tissu pour le chai
touche et le shampoing je sais tu ce
savon de marseille est également utilisé
du réseau du côté du bureau j'ai
remplacé le papier disons classique par
du papier recyclé
j'utilise aussi un moteur de recherche
qui s'appelle les concernent et qui
utilise les bénéfices générés par les
recherches des utilisateurs pour planter
des arbres dans les hautes et forestier
j'ai aussi remplacer ma bouteille d'eau
en plastique parlant gourdes
réutilisables du goûter de mon dressing
je préfère reprises et en vêtements
coréen est accro plutôt que de me jeter
directement
et si vraiment je décide comme
absolument ajouté alors là je vais
donner à l'association vient le laisse
dans un bac de tri c'est donc le mode de
finir aux déchets c'est un modèle fiable
et chacun pour qu'on puisse changer les
choses enfin bon et comme le disait marc
garneau ne nous est jamais qu en petit
groupe d'individus conscient et engagé
puisse changer les choses et que
toujours comme ça que ça s'est passé
récemment fait entendre une petite
histoire c'est l'histoire de l'effet
colibri et j'aimerais blâmable de ce
soir en fait un jour un incendie s'est
déclaré dans une forêt et la main entre
les animaux sont sauvés
tous sauf un petit coup
qui faisait des années 80 un ruisseau et
la forêt en flammes et transportés dans
son bec ou tu parles de l'eau qui peut
déverser sur la fin là vous dire que la
pudeur design mot passe bien un petit
peuple est ce sétois sont et qui
persistait mais pour une maison que le
petit colibri c'est pas mal aussi
neuilly la nef du saut à la forêt et à
la fin il me répondit c'est pas grave je
fais ma part c'est la dynamique qui
compte pour augustin si vite d'autres
personnes c'est vraiment ça l'effet
colibri c'est à lui à l'encontre des
principes ce préavis
pour changer des habitudes et montrer qu
ensemble on peut tout faire et comme ce
petit quizz vous avez tous en chacun de
vous le pouvoir de changer les choses
sauf que nous tous ensemble on ne peut
pas verser une petite côte couteau sur
un peu on veut arrêter de faire tomber
du plastique dans les océans et on
espère que lyon lille et moi ce soir on
vous a fait comprendre et prendre
conscience que vous avez tous de pouvoir
de changer les choses est de sauver la
planète
c'est à vous d'utiliser ses pouvoirs et
s'avoue de provoquer le changement et
vous pouvez commencer dès ce soir en
mettant
2 utilisable dans votre sac ou bien en
utilisant les serviettes en tissu pour
le sel et en triangle compostage de
déchets
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]